Today, we're going to talk about the different types of computers the biggest type of computer
we're going to talk about is a supercomputer which maybe you've heard of a
Supercomputer uses a whole bunch of cpus and uses something called
Parallel processing all of [those] cpus work on the same problem at the same time
The next type we're going to talk about is a server a server
holds and accesses a bunch of data or programs
Our website free code Camp is hosted on a server which stores all that information
Next let's talk about a workstation computer now a workstation computer
Just looking at it might look similar to a personal computer
But it has a bunch more power and is way more expensive toy story was built on
workstation computers now personal computers by far the most common type of computers
Maybe you've heard. I'm a mac. I'm a PC something like they're different, but really this map is still just a PC
It's a it's a personal computer. It's still a book the Mac and a PC
The last type of computer we're going to talk about is a microcontroller
Microcontroller, that's the type of tiny computer you might have in your car that has a really specialized task
And is really good that one small thing, but it's not like you could use it like a regular personal computer so just to review
[5,000] computers
supercomputer Server Workstation PC and Microcontroller